I
don't I don't agree with this marriage
that I used
Andthen
[Music]
you
don't want
how much it hurts you have to
find someone there, you know, and they find someone from
here for her to fix you
in the store there, look,
and I think  because love is very difficult
to understand
Andthen
and
I didn't imagine we are that I'm going to
marry a Brazilian
but when I find her I
can't stop trying to be with
her what the girl doesn't know where
love is like that no  takes place exactly
And it's because it's very logical
two three
four times it's
And then David Bowie is dead at Mega
affordable option so we can work in
Physical injury has back
at one Point slides on Pioneer hi-bred
I want you to know will always cut
it  that i love
and she very
good and ours will always come back manta
oscar holz all the angels
and
he thinks it
's hers got it got it
i got it i got it
i think were you have more confidence
in me it's our wedding in one day i
think the  our we go tense  so think
think pension
and I hope I hope you do
n't let me down
alright Of course
So
[Music]